scottish mutant reign sinclair has seen
it all
over the years she's died been reborn
romanced princes from other worlds and
given birth to a child
only to watch him come to a terrible end
and that's only half the story
this is the untold truth of wolfsbane
not only was wolfsbane one of the
founding members of the new mutants but
she's actually the first one to show up
in the 1982 graphic novel that
introduced the team to the world
the story opens with a wolf scaring
moira mctaggart as it leaps over her
that wolf soon transforms back into the
wounded rain sinclair
shortly after the unconscious rain
shifts to human form
her attackers appear an angry mob of men
carrying torches and shotguns led by
reverend craig
who claims to want only to save the
girl's soul moira kicks them off her
land and brings her to someone who can
actually help her
charles xavier xavier then introduces
reign to his team of new mutants but
things get off to a rocky start
when fellow new mutant karma
demonstrates her psychic abilities by
taking over moira mctaggart's mind
rain panics immediately shifts into her
transitional half-wolf form
and threatens karma and this is just the
first of many instances in which reign
loses control of her emotions wolfsbane
never had the chance to meet her birth
mother
who died during childbirth instead she
was raised by the fiery zealot
reverend craig right up until the moment
craig and his angry mobbed
chased her into the arms of moira
mctaggart reverend craig indoctrinated
reign with his religious fanaticism
to the point where she even thinks of
her own powers as gifts of satan
the shame he forces upon her leaves deep
marks in her psyche
and in most of his subsequent
appearances he vocalizes his hatred for
mutants
and is disgust at rain herself it isn't
until rain learns to combat her
emotional trauma in 1996's excalibur
number 93
that she reveals what she knows about
craig the reverend isn't just the man
who raised her
he is in fact her biological father
while confronting craig about another
mutant girl the reverend is abusing
reign tells craig that she's been
researching his past ever since she
escaped him
before he lived in kin ross craig had a
ministry in ullapool
where he met reign's mother who was a
local sex worker and his so-called
special project
when this is revealed craig collapses in
tears
driven to despair at his own hypocrisy
sadly however this isn't the last we see
of this particular villain
rain has carried a few torches over the
years and that's putting it lightly
in fact she crushes often and crushes
hard
and most likely due to the emotional
trauma she suffered at reverend craig's
hands she doesn't deal with those
crushes in the healthiest of ways
rain harbored a crush for her fellow new
mutant cipher
until the latter was shot and killed by
a bullet meant for rain
later she fell for cannonball so
intensely that when she mistakenly
thought mirage had teased her about it
she went wild and attacked her when she
first joined the new version of
x factor rain had an intense attraction
toward team leader havoc
and nothing but sheer hatred for his
romantic partner polaris
but things get much darker when reign
lies to her ex-boyfriend richter about a
pregnancy
in 2010's x factor number 208
after richter comes out as gay and rain
discovers him and shatterstar being
intimate
she goes wild and attacks shatterstar
during a lull in the fight she claims
richter is the father of her baby
in an attempt to keep him away from
shatterstar in
x-factor number 213 however richter
discovers the truth
that reign was impregnated by the wolf
prince kramhari
as part of the classic two-part tale the
asgardian wars
the new mutants are caught up in loki's
plans to destroy the x-men
surprise consequently in 1985's
new mutant special edition number one
and uncanny x-men annual number nine
the team is transported away from earth
to the other of the nine realms
wolfsbane finds herself in jotunheim
where she has a brief and passionate
affair with hrimhari
the wolf prince of asgard when the
heroes finally prevail over loki
krimhari clearly wants rain to stay with
him
but she returns with her friends
seemingly ashamed of having indulged in
her passions
it takes a couple of decades but
eventually hiram hari returns to reign
and their union brings fateful
consequences
as part of the 2004 line-wide event
avengers disassembled
ragnarok arrives and asgard is destroyed
during those events hrimhari is snuffed
out along with the rest of the asgardian
gods
like the gods however primhari is reborn
on earth
though unlike them he retains his memory
of his life before ragnarok
in 2008's x-force number 10 primhari
finds wolf's bane and they resume their
affair
reign conceives a child as a result of
their union and in 2010's
x-force number 23 trimhari is forced to
sacrifice himself to save rain and their
unborn child
marvel's x factor is one of the rare
gems that proves that a reinvention can
sometimes be more successful than the
original
when the comic premiered in 1986 it
revolved around the original x-men
hatching a very strange plan indeed
the team disguises themselves as a
mutant hunting business
their goal is rather than hunting
mutants to use the calls they receive to
find mutants who need help
ultimately the concept is discarded and
the team members eventually rejoin the
x-men
but the name isn't lost forever years
later a new government-sponsored version
of x factor is formed to help
foster trust between mutants and humans
in 1991's
x factor number 71 wolfsbane joins havoc
polaris madrox the multiple man
quicksilver and
strong guy for this new version of the
team the team's first volume ended with
1998's x-factor number 149
but it's enjoyed a number of revivals
over the years most recently in a run
that concluded in 2013.
decades after he first appeared reign's
hateful father
reverend craig reappears and decides to
become more than just a dark chapter in
wolfbane's past
he involves himself with an anti-mutant
group calling themselves the purifiers
a decision that eventually leads to his
violent death at wolf's bane's hands
but even though reign has a reputation
for losing control it's not actually her
choice to kill craig
in 2008's x-force number one wolf's bane
is captured by the purifiers
while she's there hostage she's
brainwashed as part of a plot to kill
the mutant known as angel
the team doesn't know this when they
rescue her though and when she wakes up
and sees angel a few issues later
she goes wild and attacks him ripping
off his wings during the assault
in x-force number six craig attempts to
kill wolf's bane in the same room where
angel's severed wings hang from the
ceiling
as he advances on his unwanted daughter
meaning to kill her once and for all
he briefly stands in front of the
severed wings giving him the image of an
angel rayne's brainwashing kicks in she
transforms into her half-wolf form
and reverend craig goes to meet his
maker things go badly for wolfsbane's
son
tear from the very beginning and the end
of his short life is even more dramatic
and tragic than its beginning
tear is the son of rain and the wolf
prince of asgard hrimhari
although grimhari is forced to sacrifice
himself to save wolfsbane and their
unborn child
he leaves his mark on tear before his
passing when tears born in 2011's x
factor number 224
the mystical nature of the child causes
him to exit wolf's bane's body from her
mouth
immediately upon his birth tears
instincts kick in and he kills the
mystical agamemnon
who had helped rain during her delivery
the death scares rain enough that she
abandons her newborn
he's eventually taken in and raised by
jack russell better known
as werewolf by night rain is eventually
reunited with her son who ages more
quickly than a human child
tyr is later revealed to be a central
prophecied figure in the hell on earth
war
a conflict between the different hell
lords such as pluto
satanish and mephisto whoever kills tear
is said to win the throne of hell
and in 2013's x-factor number 256
tyr even fights and almost defeats the
devilish mephisto
before tyr can finish him off however
the mutant strong guy
runs tear through from behind with a
trident killing him
and winning the throne of hell for
himself in the 2017
line-wide event secret empire hydra
takes over the united states
led by an evil version of captain
america
hey
as this happens the organization deals
with the mutant problem by granting them
a homeland called new tian in the
western part of america in the tie-in
issue
x-men blue number seven a team of x-men
confronts
agents from new tian including wolfsbane
during the melee reign demonstrates an
incredible new power
as the x-men and new team agents face
off wolf's bane locks horns with hank
mccoy
it seems that beast has wolf's being
restrained until she suddenly dissipates
into what appears to be vapor
and reforms as a pack of five wolves who
surround mccoy
beast theorizes this is a secondary
mutation
an ability that manifested itself later
in reigns development
the volume of uncanny x-men that ran
from 2018 to 2019 had a fairly high body
count
but among all the deaths depicted in the
series none caused as much of a stir
or upset fans quite as much as reign
sinclair's
which takes place in uncanny x-men
number 17.
her funeral is actually shown before her
death which is told in flashback as
wolverine and quan on hunt down her
killers
as they do this quan on uses her psychic
abilities to show logan what really
happened to rain
in the flashback a group of young men
approaches rain on a park bench and
begin to flirt with her
when she rebuffs their advances the men
get physical
and rain briefly loses control and
transforms into her half-wolf form
once the men realize she's a mutant
their attitude towards her changes
and they feel rain has somehow tricked
them into being attracted to her
after this they beat her to death
readers picked up on the scene meaning
to reflect
trans-misogyny violence and many weren't
happy about it
for example trans writer nola fal of
women write about comics
felt uncanny x-men writer matthew
rosenberg meant well
in telling this story but she also
emphasized that
when writers depict violence that occurs
against us
without bothering to depict us we are
not helped
we are not aided by this choice the
violence against us becomes normalized
but our presence does not rosenberg
publicly apologized for the hurt
caused by the storyline and urged his
followers to consider donating to trans
lifeline
despite being brutally killed in 2019's
uncanny x-men number 17
the doors to wolf's bane's return had
been opened by the end of the year
with the game-changing event dawn of x
the event sees almost all of marvel's
mutants forming a sovereign nation on
the sentient
mutant island of krakowa among other
advances made possible by the mutant's
abilities
a group is formed called the five
capable of bringing just about any
mutant back to life
as long as they have access to the
fallen mutants dna
in late 2019 new mutants was revived and
the first two pages of new mutants
number one depict the resurrection of
wolf spain
she is brought back by the efforts of
the five and greeted by professor x
and storm rain is then reunited with her
old teammates including mutants such as
sunspot and chamber
who had also been killed in earlier
comics considering the lifetime of
darkness and violence reign has endured
it can only be hoped that there are
brighter days ahead for this young
mutant
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]